live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
thank you for joining us ken coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the ken
coleman show is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five
caroline starts this hour in
philadelphia hi caroline how are you
hi i'm good thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
i am looking for advice i'm considering
making a career change in the very early
stages and looking for advice on just
things to consider and
want to make sure i make good decisions
that are not
emotions based what are you what what
what are you looking to shift to
uh i
originally was thinking so i guess a
little background with drove like drove
this twitch was
i got divorced a little over a year ago
it was unexpected there was an affair
found out a couple weeks before the
state home order so it's been a rough
couple years but
kind of getting out of that and
um realizing i don't think that the
career that i'm in right now is such a
good fit for me and that i was doing it
kind of
making career decisions mostly based on
thinking i was gonna have a family um
so kind of looking to shift that and
trying to just kind of think about
what should i be prioritizing what
you know what should what questions
should they be asking well you're not so
you're not completely sure where you
want to go you just know that you're not
where you want to be is that fair yeah
yes and so i will say i'm in all this up
and all this up evil you're saying
life's too short to do something i don't
like doing
exactly yep yep
what have you been doing
i've been a cpa since i graduated
college so about 11 years all right so
when someone presents this to me i know
that you have ideas i don't think that
your brain right now is an is an empty
chalkboard or empty whiteboard i think
you've been wondering about something or
you're at least curious about a path is
that true or false
so i was kind of dead set on wanting to
switch to teaching
for a while
and then i went and interviewed for an
apprentice role and did a demo lesson
and realized that i think this combined
was just you know i'd mapped out the
budget it would have been
you know a third of what i'm making now
what are you making right now actually
what i'm gonna do
around 140. okay 140. so so what drew
you to teaching was it the instruction
part was it the the research was it more
of a people focus i just want to
influence people what's drawing you to
these ideas that you have
so i think there were two pieces i think
part was i really like working with
people i like coaching people i like
teaching you know
younger people early on in their careers
but i think part of it too was my
ex-husband and i were just about to
start planning to have kids when we
divorced and i think a piece of it was
thinking oh i'm never going to have kids
and now at least i'll work with kids
so like when i say that emotional piece
how old are you
i'm in my mid-30s
never have kids is not necessarily true
true yeah and i think i'm starting to
see that so that's like where i'm like
oh maybe that choice was kind of more
emotional driven and what do i actually
want to do
i think that's right and i think you
need to trust that so let's go back to
the decision before you got into
cpa i'm just curious if you look at your
background what you're good at good with
numbers good at math i'm just curious
what as you start to think through that
what drew you to being a cpa was there
something that you were at least
intrigued by or is there a part of your
current work that you do enjoy that's
what i want to focus on
um i mean i like the project management
piece
i don't mind the
attention to detail working with numbers
but i think it was really just more of a
fear-based decision early on like
wanting something secure and safe sure
money okay yeah the clues right there
you gave me we want to start to lock in
on that so we know that you like project
management you're a detailed person it's
something that comes natural to you you
notice the details probably irritate you
when things aren't detailed and
efficiency is something that gives you
juice if you're involved in producing
efficiency and excellence you get fired
up is that true
no
i'm good at it because i've done it for
so long
oh yeah okay so okay great that's great
though so so now you you want to start
to focus on people focused work so i
want to drive results with people so
maybe you're thinking i want to
influence people
and and i don't mind being involved in
efficiency and strategies and that type
of work as long as it's people focused
and so i'm going to give you a quick
exercise that you can do i'm not going
to make you do it on the air because it
it puts you under under pressure but
there's an exercise for you that's going
to give you great clarity i want you to
answer these three questions before you
hit the sack tonight number one
who are the people you most want to help
allow your brain to create images and
and details second question is what
problem or desire do they have
because it's either problem focused or
desire focused uh with when it comes to
people and then the third question is
what are the solutions or a solution
that addresses that problem or desire
that's a three-part simple question
exercise
and it's going to come at this all from
different angles
people
problem or desire and then solution and
that's going to reveal to you what will
really fire you up and motivate you and
i think you're going to see
people type work
and so the final question i'll ask you i
have dave weigh in but do you find
yourself if you're honest with yourself
or people talking about you that you're
really good with people you see people
skills kind of rising to the top
um i'm not super outgoing but yeah the
older i've gotten i think
yes i have gotten that consistent
feedback let me address something you
just said just because you're not an
extrovert doesn't mean you can't be
tremendous with people that is a
misnomer it's a myth that i've got to be
mr or mrs extrovert bounce into a room
social butterfly to actually win with
people and i will tell you that
introverts actually are better at
connecting with people because of your
desire to go one-on-one in that type of
involvement so i want you to feed that
and and go this direction here's the
deal stay in this role what do you do as
a cpa
um i work mainly with non-profits doing
what
um
a variety of stuff are you doing their
taxes are you doing their books are you
teaching them to do their books what are
you doing
mainly tax work
okay
all right
which is a little bit like doing a root
canal for you
[Laughter]
you nailed it
okay so if um
but if you were working with those same
non-profits or with small businesses
teaching them
how to build a sustainable bookkeeping
and controlling system
with generally accepted accounting
principles and by the way most
nonprofits to small businesses can't
even spell gaap
right
true would that be exciting
yeah i think i want to get out of
accounting altogether one thing i've
thought about is maybe something along
the cfp lines and again background why i
found you in the first place 16 and 17
paid off a hundred ten thousand dollars
of student debt
well that is alignment with what you've
told us so far
you're the people you want to help
people with financial issues a lack of
financial literacy problem you want to
solve
solutions
still your skill set that's yeah you
have the tools in your belt already from
the cpa to give you the skill set but
you know you're not required to do
bookkeeping and taxes just because
you're a cpa
you can still use those same tools
that's what i was getting that's what i
was getting amy at and i missed
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today every time you hear someone do
their debt-free stream on this show it's
because at some point they finally said
i've had it enough
i'm not living like this anymore when
you get mad like that
and uh do what they did your life
changes
right now with inflation
recession
gas prices your stupid credit cards your
ridiculous student loans you start to
believe you're not in control well you
are in control you have to decide to
take control of what you can control and
that is by the way you the person in
your mirror you have the power to change
your future and financial peace
university is how we show you
that you can do it this course will
teach you the proven step-by-step plan
that's helped nearly 10 million people
get out of debt
master budgeting become wealthy and
outrageously generous change your family
tree and you can do this stop letting
debt and money stress control your life
say that say it i've had it say enough
enough
take back your control start financial
peace university at ramseysolutions.com
enough
ramsey solutions dot com slash enough
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure you
mess up and i have or pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
new promos all the time and they run
them all the time just use the ramsey
use ramsay as your promo code it's magic
the promo code is ramseyblinds.com
today's question comes from tom in new
york with the growing cost of living
here in the new york city area i thought
it was a good time to ask my manager for
a raise the day after our meeting they
offered me a seven percent raise and i
was ecstatic an hour later they
backtracked and said my raise would
actually be only three percent i'm
grateful for the raise but this
backtracking on the amount felt like a
slap in the face should i just be
grateful or should i try to negotiate
oh dave this is uh
some type of leadership fail here
yeah this is just really bad i don't
think it's a slap in the face tom i
think it's a gut punch and that's normal
to feel that way
i don't think you can renegotiate here
because i think this is a clear sign of
a leadership error somebody spoke out of
their hat um and they couldn't deliver
what they said they were going to
deliver so yeah that's what they did
well i've tried to choose the g-rated
option for today's show bleep you out of
our own show exactly that's
family-friendly folks but i don't think
renegotiation is the option here i'll
tell you what i would do i want to know
why that's what i would do i think you
got to sit and go hey listen uh i feel
like i've been kicked in the gut and i i
just want to know what happened between
the time you told me seven and an hour
later when you told me three i think
that's fair to ask
um because i don't know
i'm not trying to be ungrateful i'm not
trying to be a jerk but you know i mean
put yourself in my shoes when you feel a
little weird about that so i feel a
little weird about it i want to know
during that hour did i do something
wrong no i probably didn't so what
happened okay well i i overspoke and my
boss slapped me down and maybe you know
maybe maybe made me drop it to three
because i didn't really have the budget
to do it okay that's helpful to at least
have that experience that's correct and
information right i mean and so it still
doesn't change it all together you still
get the same amount of money but you
know if you know why
then that makes a lot of difference i
think that's incredible advice there
because it's the gut punch it's still
there but if you know what happened and
you understand that sometimes people
make mistakes and they wanted to give it
to you i would be grateful in this
situation i would be grateful for the
three percent if it's a legitimate
reason um but if you're gonna have to
move bureaucratic yeah that would bother
me but whole answer i'm looking for a
job hundred percent
because here's what happens we just
don't do that right you know well yeah
we don't we don't give people seven
percent raises uh wait a minute you did
you said that's correct and that's the
difference between being valued and an
organization a healthy leader is going
to go i blew it dude
i actually blew it
well they should have said that with the
they should have on the three percent
they should have not done it start with
but uh you know uh because you don't
stepped in it dude it is seven percent
and that's what would happen here i'm i
might kick the leader's butt that made
the mistake but uh but the guy's getting
his seven because we told him he's
getting a seven oh i was going to ask
you how would you handle that situation
i mean you know unless we didn't have
the money right if we simply didn't have
the money but if it's just a
bozo thing then you know leader leaders
you know
i had one of our leaders um
we you know we we teach that you know if
you're going to confront someone you
talk
talk to them about the things they're
doing right we talk about this behavior
that's wrong and then we talk about
things that they're doing right a
sandwich right it's a one-minute manager
thing right and um
uh you know and so you know you want to
you want to call it a uh whatever a
sandwich right so uh
and uh one of our leaders was fairly new
and i just went and said look that sucks
don't do that again and he goes where's
the sandwich
well you're a leader you get no bread
you just get the meat
that's funny that's where you're if
you're a leader you get you just get the
information right but you know i'll give
you the sandwich if i'm leading a
subordinate but i mean you just screwed
this up and you're supposed to be acting
like you run the place so oh my god yeah
that's uh so you're eating the seven
percent out of your budget yeah and uh
in your area and we're going to figure
it out but if if not if there's
absolutely no money and it was truly a
financial error that has to be changed
then you've at least got to learn how to
uh
to explain something like this it
doesn't make it that much better it
makes it does it makes it a lot better
yeah it does a solid reason humans will
listen to yes honesty to say i messed up
i messed up and here's what happened
and here's what you know and i got you
know
my boss took my freaking head off when i
went in there because i messed this up i
overstepped my bounds and it's so it's
on me it's my fault you own it and you
know that that's just like
human
this quick leadership lesson here folks
with what dave just said if you as a
leader don't own everything and give
them all the details that you can
possibly give them meaning you leave it
as a vacuum in their mind they will fill
it with their own narrative and that's
where it becomes toxic and dangerous you
as the leader got to make sure that the
narrative is correct yeah when in doubt
people don't believe positive things
without information they immediately
believe negative i agree so these
companies that their communication is
mushroom communication keep everybody in
the dark and feed them manure
it doesn't work no it doesn't work
that's corporate america though
all right kimberly is with us kimberly
is in tucson hi kimberly how are you
hi dave i'm doing great how are you
better than i deserve how can i help
great hey so i am in baby step number
two i have fifty six thousand dollars of
student loans and a car payment that
i've been
paying off very quickly um putting
anywhere from fifteen hundred to two
thousand dollars a month
towards my debts
and
i'm trying to pull all of the levers to
get me out of the in the next two years
and
one of the options i have is to get a
roommate for my
spare bedroom and
so i haven't been in a roommate
situation for about
i don't know seven eight years now and
so i'm wondering if
like what is the best way for me to
manage my finances um for this split
and what i was calculating yesterday was
based off of the last three months of
rent plus the utilities the average cost
would be 15.70 a month for
um for all in total and so divided by
two would leave me 780 but
i felt like it was fair to
drop it down to 700 because
i have an office in the house
so i'm using more room of the house and
i also have the carport which is a
luxury in tucson arizona
so
i'm wondering really my question is
should i
go down the path of lumping the
utilities in
to the rent as a you know and advertise
this
spare bedroom as 700
utilities included
or should i do a rent price and then
split utilities every month with the um
roommate
i would do including utilities as long
as when you look at the place where
you're going to advertise it that that's
what other people are doing
okay and here's why here's exactly what
i saw too that's why as long as the 700
doesn't change
nothing changes here but every month the
utilities change and when that price
goes up the price goes down the price
goes up the price goes down and you have
to go through this additional collection
procedure every single month yeah you're
kind of giving them a reason to
re-evaluate every month whether they
stay
yeah i i'm kind of good with them
getting bored
yeah and it's a little bit higher on the
emotional side
you gotta do it with two or three
collections i mean or instead of just
the rent you can also collect your
proportion the water you push the gas or
portion of whatever
and so it's just a lot cleaner a lot
simpler a lot less stress on everybody a
little more boring
and i would do that
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today number one best-selling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
yeah you can have purpose in your
paycheck it'll work and you can have a
paycheck in your purpose too
it'll all work bob and liz are with us
in portland oregon says on my screen you
guys are debt free congratulations
well thank you mr ramsey it's a pleasure
and an honor to speak to you you too sir
how much did you guys pay off
uh 206 000
over approximately 42 months yay and
your range of income during that time
uh 160 to 112. wow down i love it what
do you guys do for a living
well we're both retired now but we i
worked for the telephone company and my
wife was a registered nurse okay and so
at the end of this you pulled the plug
on it huh
yeah pretty much yes literally within a
month of uh paying off the house
we were you have 112 000 retirement
income
yes what is you what how old are you
guys
i am 66 my wife is 63. very cool so what
kind of debt was the 206
uh
pretty much all house mortgage we've
been
free of other debt for several years now
the 206 was our mortgage and then a
thousand dollars for an emergency fund
and a thousand dollars i believe a visa
bill wow
you guys are incredible you're weird i
love you
well done well done all right so uh what
happened
uh what four year three and a half years
ago
here's my wife
hi bob i mean hi hi
hi so
i was listening to your show about three
and a half years ago and you had some
old guy on there and he was like i paid
off blah blah blah blah and you were
like well how old are you and he's like
77 or something i can't even remember
the whole thing but i thought i am 59 i
do not want to retire with a house
payment
so that i just we
followed your steps we have been doing
davis for a while we i decided to do it
and we just went
you know we just did your steps i
stopped so you went and told bob hey i
was listening to some old guy on the
radio before before i get old i don't
want to be like i want to be like him i
want to be dead free what'd bob
say uh i've i've actually
been you know we've been working toward
this point
for a number of years it wasn't a hard
sale then
oh no not at all i mean it's
you know i remember when we got out of
debt except for a mortgage payment right
when our daughter went into college that
was such an outstanding point because
we were able to pay college
out of our
basically our monthly budget and there
was no debt involved in our daughter
being in college yeah and that is such
and
as you have said that's a freeing
thing
how many years have you all been married
we've been married 37 years have you had
a house payment the whole time
yeah yes so the other day when you paid
the house off was the first time in your
married life you've been a hundred
percent free
yeah
yeah did you feel it physically when you
did that did you like it like a switch
flipped
no not really because it was a point we
were working toward
we got there we knew we were gonna get
there
and it was just like kind of like
anticlimactic a blessing
like say thank you yeah well we're proud
of y'all well done
it was what kind of what kind of
happened was
you know he went from 160 to 112 just
immediately so
so it was like our income would drop so
i think we've had two months now without
a house payment
and you know i retired and you know we
kind of ran around i think once we
settled down
we will notice it oh i said it's like
you know we've been going crazy you know
you cut your income considerable that
does make sense yeah yeah and you know
what i'm fine with it yeah i mean well
simultaneously you cut your income so
it's like you didn't really experience
the
extra house payment coming into your
checking account not having to go out
yeah that makes sense exactly yeah but
you are free
yes
okay so someone's listening it's 59 and
they're wondering if they're too old
to talk to them
okay i would say you're never told i
don't care if you're
you know 80.
there's you can do it i mean obviously
you know we i had a good income
but i didn't work any overtime or
anything i just
what really changed
what we really think helped a lot was
you know we've always tithed
and god was so gracious to us
during our time that we
were like
didn't have any backup really we the way
we got our three-month emergency fund
was from a car accident
and
other than that we only had 15 000 which
you know is a little bit of money but
it was it was the graciousness of god
truly is
how we were able to do it i mean that's
that's what i think anyway
well liz you you've mentioned a couple
times you guys went crazy you've been
running around you haven't even had a
chance to really absorb the fact that
you've gone two months without a house
payment i'd love folks to hear what that
discipline was what was the craziness
what did you guys do to tighten down uh
the hatches and really get after this
thing
well we did nothing
nothing i mean literally we didn't take
any trips oh right
we i like i was returning bottles i
don't know if tennessee you can return
bottles but i think people that i worked
with thought it was like
stupid
you know just you know you don't buy
books you go to the library you know you
cook at home you don't eat out
you know
it was a little bit of a drudgery was it
worth it i mean if if i had to do it
again i'd do it over seven years rather
than four
ah okay
all right that's good advice well well
done you two
very very proud of you here you head
into retirement not a house payment not
a payment in the world and a great
income you are set
very very very well done you'll get to
do anything you want to do at this point
so proud of you all how much do you have
in your nest egg
oh uh we have about
we we both have pensions we both have
social security and we have
approximately
seven hundred and fifty thousand dollars
and what in our 401ks and what's uh
what's the house worth
uh
650 000 maybe wow so how many so you're
millionaires at 66 years old
congratulations you're baby step
millionaires you followed the baby steps
to get there uh did you uh inherit any
large sum of money to cause you to be
there
no i i inherited 1300 once but that's
been it okay
that laugh was for you millennials that
think that all money is inherited
that was the best sarcastic laugh i've
heard in a week that was fabulous
well done all right we've got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you you
should have been in the book you is one
also got a copy of financial peace
university the uh one-year membership to
that you can give that away and get
somebody started on this same journey
you're on they put you in this position
we're so proud of you guys very well
done and even a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away as well
bob and liz portland oregon 206 000 paid
off in 42
months making 160 to 112 because they
retired when they paid off the house
that's how that worked count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
i love it
oh that's so fun
she reminds me of my grandpa when he was
uh
like 80 he would say that old man down
the street right right and she's like
that old man is 77 years old
this old man called in
yes you got to love liz she went high
there too like bob was pretty you could
tell her personalities in that call you
know on the screen like bob was steady
liz went up high there she was very
excited i hope bob takes her out to a
really nice steak dinner
or whatever kind of dinner she wants
that's true she deserves it for putting
up with you bob
that's it that's the way it is
yeah she's married to one of them old
men
that's true she delivered bottles so is
my wife sharon
[Laughter]
i love it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
thank you for joining us america brandon
is with us next he is in raleigh north
carolina hi brandon how are you
i'm not gonna lie i'm a little nervous
actually what goes into my question is
that i'm taking my real estate exam come
friday good for you literally in the
process of studying for that how old are
you i have to give you a little uh 28.
good for you that's fun i have to i have
to give you a little bit of hard time
because you tell people not to book with
you know your uncle your brother-in-law
who just got their license a month ago
and i'm just letting you know you're
cutting into my business like that's who
i am now you already passed the test yet
we're not worried about you cutting into
your business
yeah that's a fair point that's a fair
point so i'm a little hurt every time
you say i'm like no my panda's gonna
hear this and they're not gonna call me
my question actually pertains to that
i'm moving from
uh having more of like a standard you
know monthly or by you know five-month
weekly i should say paycheck to now i'm
working off commission um my wife and i
are neither particularly disciplined
when it comes to budgeting it's always
an issue for us and so we are
this like new season of kind of having a
income fluctuate and i was just looking
for like tips or just like how do i go
about when i just don't know when it's
you know when it's going to be pouring
and rain you know money's going to be
falling or when it's you know a dry
season um and that looks like and so how
do i how do i kind of navigate that
especially when it comes to like
investing or even like a mortgage
looking to eventually buy a house at
some point all of that okay your wife
work outside the home
um she does at the moment
um she makes about 1500 a month okay
all right and so we know we've got that
coming in and the first things you're
going to do with money are food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities so
buy food first
make sure your utilities are paid second
pay your rent third
and you probably don't need a ton of
clothing you probably have enough most
americans do
and um food shelter clothing
transportation you gotta make sure your
cars are running um and you probably can
do a lot of that on her 1500 agreed
yeah i mean do some bit of it for sure
yeah and and so that kind of takes the
pressure off because if you're warm and
fed and dry
because you're under a roof and there's
heat and there's food in your
refrigerator
your your psychology your emotions are
in a different complete a completely
different place even if you just did it
all in your mind that just now you feel
a little bit more peaceful than just oh
god how are we going to eat well we got
her 1500 that's just calm your butt down
you know so that's you what you're doing
is you're working through the facts and
that starts to dissipate the irrational
fears then the re reasonable fears are
those things um
to uh
that everybody has and and then what
we're going to do is everything that
doesn't get paid
that's the most important things from
her 1500 we're just going to make a list
of those things and you can visualize
doing it with a yellow pad
and just make a list of them you can do
it you can do it in the every dollar app
you can do it wherever you want to do it
but just make a list of those things and
then go okay if we if if i make one sale
and we can do
three or four more things than we made
with hers what are we gonna do what
we're gonna do what's the most important
next thing and then the next most
important and put a one by that what's
the next most important thing put a two
by that the next most important thing
put a three by that and you go on down
the list and
you know and here's the thing
in the real estate business you're not
going to make many sales that close
within the same month that you make the
sale
most of the time you got about a 30-day
lead time minimum
now uh and if you list the house in this
current market you're the listing agent
that's what we call money in the bank
because there's a shortage of inventory
right now so that puppy's going to sell
so you can project a commission on that
out there 60 to 90 days within 60 to 90
days maybe sooner
and
certainly if you have a deal under
contract that has to close by the end of
next month you know next month that
commission's likely going to be there
it's not 100 but you can start to plan
pretty intelligently so you're not going
to suddenly make thousand dollars in a
month you didn't see coming you're not
going to suddenly make zero in a month
that you didn't see coming
okay does that make sense
yeah because if you're going into a
month that has zero in the pipeline
you're probably going to make zero
if you're going into a month you're
going to look at buying action yeah well
you don't actually want to go looking at
buying a house well when you get to that
point when you get to that point you
will have stabilized your real estate
income and you'll have a somewhat
predictive
you know you go in a year i make 60 000
bucks that's 5 000 bucks a month average
some months i make 10 some months i make
two but the average is about five and
you would very seldom have a zero month
in the real estate business if you're
ready to buy a house
brandon are you in a full-time job now
um i am i'm working at the moment uh
when i was moving out here i wanted a
job that
i
like would pay some bills and take care
of us kind of in the meantime but i
wouldn't get comfortable at because i
want to keep myself hungry keep pushing
for the real estate so i'm working
currently at like
a grocery store doing something like
that in the meanwhile okay
how much you're making there
um there i'm making about right now
making it about two thousand a month oh
good yeah so i the reason i asked that
and dave weigh in on this but brandon i
would have you listen you're going
through the process of getting the
certification and getting qualified to
do it but the reality is is that there's
there's no shame in you going right i
want to try to pad my my transition a
little bit and i would even challenge
i'm fi i love the theory that you've got
there i actually like the way your
head's at like i i don't want to be in a
really cushy comfortable job because i
want to stay motivated i like where your
head's at but in this economy right now
you could go get another part-time job
and and make an additional fifteen
hundred another two thousand dollars a
month and stu stock uh stack some money
away
so that when you go all in uh with what
dave just gave you you guys have some
padding there you know what i'm saying i
i just would consider that because i
think to win you know you got to go all
in as a real estate agent
and you can keep working at the grocery
store while you start your real estate
career i agree the first three or four
months that's what i'm getting at yeah i
mean you know give yourself an on-ramp
here yeah and uh because it takes a
little while
just to know how to you know
how to find the parking spot you know
how to walk in there and how to fill out
a contract i want to get your take on
this i would i'm going to assume that a
stressed out agent who's trying to feed
themselves early on is going to come
across that way sure sure
broke salesman smell bad right so let's
take that pressure off of ourselves for
this career that we love let's take the
pressure off to provide with that
initially especially in a straight
commission job like that yeah i don't
think you're gonna struggle no and i'll
suddenly become lazy
from working at a grocery store no he's
driven you know i don't think that's
gonna happen you're gonna be fine with
that yeah i would keep as much income
coming in as you can until but as you
get to the point that you can take the
training wheels off yes and go full time
so to speak
uh or really you need to go full time
now but work still work part time at the
grocery store you know that kind of
thing but uh uh
but as you're as you're counting
exclusively on the real estate
commissions you will have a better
rhythm for the pipeline and then you
would use the system that we just talked
about a prioritized spending plan most
important thing to least important thing
and uh let me tell you what happens on
the real estate business because i grew
up in the business and i uh
i made this mistake in my early years
you get a nice big check-in
and you want to jump over and do the big
thing
because that check you know i got 3 800
bucks here and there's a 3800 bill
laying here i could do that and
and then you you look up and you go oh
we didn't pay the light bill
uh but i did get rid of that big thing
you know or i did purchase that big
thing i was even worse about doing that
which is really bad oh yeah but yeah um
yeah and so
you cannot out earn your stupidity you
have to have a system and a process that
gives the most important thing the
highest priority all the way through and
keep working that
that's the best way to do that but here
but here's the thing straight commission
is not a problem as long as you're
making money yes it's all about the
pipeline you've said that a couple times
i used to have a straight commission
sales job and let me tell you something
uh your confidence grows as your
pipeline fills
because then you go oh i learned how to
fill the pipeline and now i keep filling
it and now it becomes a continuation now
you're rolling if you've been making two
thousand dollars a month in a grocery
store and you start making 300 000
you'll figure out how to budget that's
right you'll find a way to do it so i
mean you
you know all of a sudden fluctuating
income is not a problem that's correct
fluctuating income's biggest problem
when there's not much of it that's when
it's a problem yeah so go make a pile of
money dude and go be so excellent that
you become one of our endorsed local
providers one of our ramsey trusted
people
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is done cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status simple choice
we help people build wealth through work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
ken coleman ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book paycheck to purpose is my co-host
today we'll be answering your questions
about everything you want to talk about
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five samantha
starts this hour in minnesota hi
samantha how are you
hi samantha hi uh dave this is ellis and
thanks for taking my call oh shoot i'm
sorry i said my name
oh boy um starting off good here my
question is that um i am wondering
whether i need to sell my home to pay
off the rest of my debt or whether i
need to
accept a gift from my parents to pay off
the debt
okay uh how old are you
i'm 35 and how much do you own your home
i owe about 250. how much other debt do
you have
about 12 000.
i have um worked that down quite a bit
thanks to your help um
but
it's i keep on bouncing back and forth
between baby step one and two now um
just based on recent events that keep
putting things in my path
okay like what
um well like last summer my ac went out
um this year i've had a lot of vet bills
in medical what do you mean
i make 80 000 a year okay well vet bills
in an ac should not [ __ ] you making
80 grand a year
i'm sorry yeah i have made a lot of
progress
how quick would you pay off 12 000 if we
took all this out of the equation if it
was just up to you
just up to me um i could probably get it
out you know and then i mean
if i took on like another weekend job
probably you know six to eight months
yeah that sounds right
okay
and so uh and and and so you don't have
to sell your house to get out of debt
my
my house is a little bit more than my um
and then the 25 that you recommend
though of my a little bit more doesn't
make me sell it
okay your house is not out of line i
mean your house is close to outline but
it's not it's not 50 of your take-home
pay
no no
you know it's it might be 28 or
something right
no well with the hoa it's 30 percent
yeah it's not going to kill you
it's not going to kill you this is a
guideline to keep you from being
houseboards so it's not a it's not a
pharisee thing where if you're one and a
half percent over you got to sell your
house it's not it's not what we're doing
we're just trying to say don't be house
poor and you're not house poor i'd
rather you be a little bit lower but i
don't think you have to sell your house
unless you want to sell your house okay
so if mom and dad give you twelve
thousand dollars uh what's the downside
of that are they controlling are they
going to be
giving you a hard time or
no no i think you know the i would want
to pay it back to them you know anyway
just you know before they retire that's
not it's not a gift that's a loan
so the downside is they don't really
have the 12 000
they're too broke
how much do they have
are they millionaires
yes then they don't need twelve thousand
dollars from you
it's a gift
hello
yeah i'm here okay
i just don't want to be feel like i'm
enabling myself in a situation that
is going to that is that isn't good for
me like because for example the loan i
have on my house is a 30-year loan it's
not a 15-year loan like you recommend
so i
you know i've been kind of coaching
myself to get in more of the mindset
where i get into you know a house
15-year loan set
um you know interest rate and then um
and potentially sell this house and i
just feel like
i accept that that gift from them i'm
kind of enabling myself
no the 12 000 is going away still the
house is still exactly the same
situation
so it's not enabling the house it's
enabling the debt but you've already
broken the cycle on the debt haven't you
yeah i i think so um i hope so
i mean just the fact that
yeah have they given you money before
and you've messed back up and fallen off
the wagon
they have given they helped me with the
down payment on my house and i did pay
that back to them though okay
all right
okay
okay here's the thing you're 35 years
old you do not have to prove your
maturity to your parents
by
repaying it's not like well she needs to
learn her lesson
no you don't that's not that's not the
thing okay that's just not a thing if
you can accept the gift and there's no
strings attached and your parents aren't
freaks and they're not dogging you about
going on vacation after you got a 12 000
gift from them or something like that
then i think you should learn to accept
the gift you need to learn to be a a
receiver as well as a giver and no it is
not a loan do not take it as a loan
either don't take it
or take it as a gift
and um and i don't think that makes you
irresponsible and i don't think you're
enabling nothing you've told me
indicates that i would tell you you know
i would
dave i think i hear some self-loathing
or some you're still punishing yourself
like you've bought into the baby steps
and you believe it and listen you've
done a great job to get to this moment
yeah you don't need to feel guilty about
receiving a gift that will fast forward
you being able to start paying your
house off and i just sense that you feel
just the fact that you said i i don't
want to enable like you're still feeling
shame and guilt over maybe past
financial decisions i think you got to
be free from that yeah rear view mirrors
are smaller than windshields and that's
called grace
so you look in the rearview mirror
enough to not to stay aligned and but it
doesn't define your future your future
is defined by the windshield so here's
what i would do if i woke up in your
shoes and then you can go do whatever
you want okay
number one as i said i'm not gonna do
anything as a loan period no relative
loans no loans we're out of the debt
business period shifting it from
relative to relative debt from credit
card debts dumb idea just pay it off
forget it okay if you're going to take
it take it as a gift and a smile no
strings attached no problems number one
number two as far that leaves us with
just the house then and the 80 000
income and a 30-year mortgage is the 30
of your income including hoa do you have
to sell that no should you reevaluate it
yes
and i would what i would do if i woke up
in your shoes as i'd take the gift i'd
pay off the debt i'd set my budget up
and i'd work on my career to get my
income up enough that i could start
paying this house like a 15 at a
reasonable rate so if you got your
income to 100 000 this whole thing
changes and so i'm going to give myself
36 months to get my income to 100 to 110
otherwise i'm going to talk about
selling the house if i'm stuck at 80 for
the next five years i'm probably gonna
sell the house but if i can see a curve
on my income going up and this house
starts to be a smaller and smaller
percentage of my income therefore i can
put it on a 15 year schedule because i'm
debt free because i accepted the gift
and i'm on a budget then i'm keeping the
house
but
nothing uh
uh you are you are a very precise very
detailed person
and that works to your advantage in this
case you are have got a little bit of
paralysis of the analysis
and so um
i in other words cut yourself some slack
kiddo
you're doing so much better than your
emotions and your sentence structure
tells us you think you're doing
so i think you're doing great that's how
i would play it if you want to this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsay to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
in less than two weeks we're kicking off
the building wealth tour
and uh it's been incredible to see the
buzz around these life-changing events
at these events
you'll learn the best way to buy to
build real lasting wealth it's me and
ken coleman dr john deloney george
campbell rachel cruz yesterday we
announced a sellout
in san antonio
and there was a few tickets left in the
second phoenix night today i'm gonna
tell you phoenix is sold out both nights
so it's gone it's gone we have one city
that is not sold out that's minneapolis
and they have uh less than about 60 or
70 tickets so if you want to come to the
live event this fall called building
wealth you are going to be in
minneapolis unless you already have your
ticket passes start as low as 25 you can
get a four pack starting at 60
bring a group of your friends and come
out to building wealth i'll be speaking
we'll be doing panel discussions we'll
be signing books taking pictures hanging
out with you guys and we are ready to go
so phoenix september 12 and 13 sold out
thank you phoenix thank you ktr ktar
listeners we love you guys sacramento
november the 1st sold out minneapolis
november the 10th almost
sold out i'm not kidding you people get
your tickets san antonio november
it doesn't have the date on here where
did
where is it
15th sold out november 15th sold out so
it's exciting oh it's very exciting i'm
glad we're going from minneapolis to san
antonio i'm a southerner and i need to
thaw out after that november of
minneapolis day that's a great city
no it's just a bad joke yeah minneapolis
is a great great great city for all
things ramsey's always great crowds all
of these markets as you can tell these
are all three to five thousand person
venues yeah just unbelievable response
so thank you guys we appreciate it turns
out there's still a lot of capitalist
pigs out there they want to learn how to
build well
that's us man sound effects brought to
you by dave ramsey himself we believe it
man we believe it
we is that all right brock's with us
speaking of minneapolis brock do you
have your tickets yet
i actually do i'll be there awesome very
nice awesome you know anybody needs to
come
uh well probably almost everyone in
minneapolis to be honest with you but
for sure for sure there's four of us
coming okay hey for sure i'm going to
give you two more tickets to give to
some of your friends right that's fun
all right i will definitely take those i
got some people in mind okay when we get
done i'll put you on hold i'll just give
them to you how can we help well i need
some advice here speaking of being a
capitalist pig
basically the last four years i've been
working at a electronic repair shop and
it's been great but i have determined
it's my time to leave
and now i'm at kind of a weird
crossroads so it's either in the last
four years i found a side hustle that
i've been extremely blessed at and in
doing and essentially for the part-time
work it's been equivalent to my current
salary per year
or it's either i continue doing my side
hustle and make it into a full-on
business
or maybe just because i do have a
background in some sort of i.t working
at this electronic repair shop would it
be better to go more corporate style i.t
by going through like the proper
certifications get a corporate 40-hour
week job
so i'm essentially trying to ask
when did you determine that it was a
good fit to try to be an entrepreneur
and to potentially make more than what a
corporate safe
job would be
uh well i want dave to answer that from
his standpoint but but real quick you
know jim collins who wrote the book good
to great in a whole series of books
under under really the most famous
research done on company strength uh he
once got a question like this from one
of his business school students and he
looked at him and he said what makes you
think the corporate job is so safe
because you can't control uh a leader
doing something crazy like an enron
situation he said if you want to
paint your own portrait with your own
business i would tell you that that is
more safe
uh long term because you are controlling
what you are doing with the business and
you've proven
to this point that you've got this thing
going and right now sustained it at a
level uh and you could grow it
presumably so the corporate it job uh to
me it could be a both and it would the
corporate i.t job uh make you more money
in the short term and allow you to put
more resources into the side hustle
until you get that side also built up to
the point that you can walk from the day
job right into the side hustle but that
is also based on the fact that would you
go all in on your business right now if
you knew it would pay you what you're
making now and then some so what's the
answer to that question
yeah i mean the answer is like right now
you know i'm currently at the you know
my salary position i'm doing full time
and at this point i've already racked up
all the part-time hours besides you know
going into sleep schedule right so i
don't think i could expand it anymore
whether i'm in my current job or a
different job
but in terms of being able to put into a
viable business
essentially the only thing i'm really
missing is retail and then a retail
location and then obviously putting all
my full-time effort into it so how much
cash would you need to have because we
don't want you to ever go into debt to
try to expand a business so how much
cash would you need in the form of
resources to be able to go full time on
the side hustle
um i would say a good nest egg would be
anywhere between 80 to 90 to start off
with that should cover my first year
essentially then the corporate id job
i'm halfway there okay so so you're
halfway there so let's call it your 45
40 45 and so the corporate it job would
become a very viable option for me if i
were in your shoes if it allowed me to
make more money so that i can get to
that nest egg faster
okay
is this a stepping stone though it's not
an answer
it's just a stepping stone that's right
it's not long
right and if i were to take like some
sort of like corporate i.t job it
wouldn't be
necessarily exactly what i'd be doing on
my own business what is your own
business
so essentially i buy and sell and
refurbish electronics that people don't
want
and then i you know sell them on online
platforms and then obviously corporate
it job is going to be more so uh trying
to sustain and customer or not customer
client help or uh even you know internal
helping of i.t issues
yeah that's brilliant
okay
yeah your side hustle's killer
it's killer um
there's really no wrong answer here bro
what are you making now a year
currently my salary is about 55 and then
i'm on track for this year my side
hustle i should clear about 50 to 60.
can you live on 50 to 60
i mean i used to be living on 40 so no i
wouldn't ask i said can you live on 50 i
think that's what you used to do
are you married i could
nope i'm single well my girlfriend is
probably going to be listening to this
can you pay your bills
yes on 50 to 60
yep and i have no debt
can you not open with the 45 you've got
and keep making 50 to 60.
so right now i just got out of the
marine corps reserve i just did my six
years
so the reason why i'm leaving my current
job is because i'm trying to continue my
service and i'm thinking of going
national guard or air national guard so
that's going to be a natural break since
i'll have to leave potentially for three
to nine months to get trained in this
new military occupation
i figured on my way back once i finally
get back
then i would probably start the business
or continue to get certifications to go
uh
uh listen i'm a huge fan of the national
guard and the military thank you for
your service i'm so confused why you're
confused
why do you need to go do that
uh you know i just feel like it's just a
calling that i have i just enjoy
i enjoy the people i i like the clowns
maybe not the circus in its entirety but
uh you know to be able to to get some
sort of change with and lead people is
what i really enjoyed at least in the
marine corps
feels bifurcated to me it's like you got
three different things you're passionate
about you need to pick one
yeah i i would agree i think it's going
to hurt your dream of making the side
hustle the full-time gig
already making 45 000 a year 50 000
you're doing the thing you think you
want to go do love go do that and lead
people
and serve your country by being a small
business person
um i'm not opposed to being in the
military but i would i would pick
i wouldn't take nine months off shut
your business down then come back and
try to open it
you're chasing your tail man you make a
call here this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today open phones at eight eight two
five five
two two five tracy is with us in fort
myers florida hi tracy how are you
hi it's a pleasure to speak to you both
you too how can we help
so yesterday i was laid off whoa
well sounds like it was unexpected
it was however i'm in a rare situation
from i think a lot of people in that i
recently came into some inheritance a
decent chunk i am completely debt-free
including the house
so
and it's within like my mom died on
christmas day and i it's it's all this
has been a heck of a year anyway um
thank you and so i my job i'm in hr i
have sleep privileges where i work and
so
the irony is i sold my personal car that
i hadn't driven in a year last week
and now i have 13 days to get a car so
no notice at all on this layoff that's
just weird
no no yeah i mean it's it is what it is
i'm just trying to roll with the punches
and i think
the the scariest part for me is i now
have more money than i've ever had and i
still and you know you're not supposed
to make big major decisions with
grief being so recent i what was the car
that you sold last week what was it
it was a 2012 hyundai elantra
and what did you sell it for
four thousand and they put it online for
8 900.
whoa they turned around and re-flipped
it on you huh
oh yeah i mean the pictures while i was
waiting for them to come back with how
much they were going to give me they
the the pictures i had the place and
everything on it that um they end up
bringing back me so
it was crazy but um
how much money do you how much money do
you have in cash
oh i have over five hundred thousand
okay so
so go buy a car what's the problem
well because i am not used to having
this kind of money and my mindset is
still that i should go get a cheap car a
hooptie but i know after working in the
realm that i've worked in where i could
drive a different car all the time i
know what i want i'm just afraid to
spend that kind of money because i've
never had that choice before so i just
feel like i need permission from you to
say yeah go out and spend 40 000 on you
i really wanted grand cherokee
okay but they're expensive okay are you
buying a one-year-old one or something
a couple years yeah i don't know that
i'd want to go more than two or three
okay what did you make at your job that
you got lost
75
and what are you going to make at the
next job 85
i hope so and honestly i'm kind of i'm
not i don't know that i need to look
right now with the holidays
i need to
it's going to be crazy with the first
year without my mom that she died on
christmas day so i think this is a sign
that i should just kind of
not rush into anything until maybe after
the first of the year you guys tell me
but that's kind of where i'm thinking
right now
okay there's two separate questions on
the table
number one let's deal with the easy one
go buy a car
and yes you can afford it you can afford
a forty thousand dollar car you have a
half million dollars cash in the bank
you make you make eighty thousand 000 a
year you do not want to buy a 70 000 car
no i would never
buy it well you might i mean i'm just
making sure okay okay and uh but i mean
if i wouldn't spend more than half of
what you think you're going to be making
okay and so 40 with you making 80 is
okay
60 with you making 80 is not okay
right just because you got the money
okay so that that would be my guideline
and so that gives you permission to do a
lot
and just take and take your time on that
go rent your car for a week so you're
not in a hurry and get and pay too much
for a car
and that's what i was afraid of yeah
just slow down go just go down the
rental car place and rent a car for a
week
okay and just rent what you think you
want to drive by the way go ahead and
rent your jeep cherokee well the irony
is that i just got laid off from a
rental car company so that's why i know
what i want to drive
okay
this gets better and better every minute
yeah been almost two years of driving
pretty much whatever i like so i mean i
know what i want let's move on to the
next question and i want my career
expert next to me to step in but i'm
gonna before he does i'm just gonna be
papa dave okay
okay you lost your mom
and then your surprise
got kicked in the teeth
and you walked in and got devalued
instantaneously last week
so you're confident your confidence is a
little bit shaken
and um
i would prefer you get back on the horse
quicker than the first of the year for
that reason because i want you to get
back on the horse because i want you to
regain some of your some of your swagger
and just the grieving of your mom which
is fine and normal and you should
uh but also in the middle of that you
had somebody walk in and say you don't
have any value hit the street
and i i want to tell you you got a lot
of value
thank you and when you land that new job
that's them telling you you've got a lot
of value and i don't want you to wait
till the first year to hear that message
again
okay that's just papa dave talking but
ken no i appreciate it no i i agree with
that um because you're really a victim
of a lot of fear out there around
recession and things like this and a lot
of companies they staff up and then they
staff down and it really wasn't personal
at all it's why you really didn't even
see it coming we hear about this every
day my question is do you have a
severance at all
uh yeah just two weeks because i've not
been there quite two years yeah well i i
think i would echo dave and what i want
you to do though is i like the idea of
reflection and you've got you've got at
least a month uh you know before you
know of just kind of going where do i
want to go and looking into all of the
possibilities but you know one of the
the big hiring times for a lot of
companies is it in november and so i i
would actually take advantage of of
getting back on the horse pre-holiday we
still have a very hot job economy so i
want you thinking now because you've got
financial freedom
what is it that you really want to do
and why do you want to do it i'm just
curious you got something in the top of
your mind without trying to make it
sound pretty what is something that you
would do what is it tell me
i've always want to be in real estate
but i'm afraid because the market is so
saturated with realtors um yeah markets
slowed down that that calls them out
pretty quick yeah i mean i've thought
about this for 10 years and i've just
never done it because
because the people who are in it that i
that i've asked the questions i mean
they're real you're gonna pay a lot of
things out of your own pocket you might
not make money the first year you know
if that's scary now i have that freedom
i know i could but i'm still
it's still hot it's hard for me to wrap
my head around the amount of money that
i have and so in my mind i keep trying
to forget about it so that i don't go
crazy well okay so i want dave to
comment on the real estate the guy's
been in real estate a long time and he
knows but i just want to tell you
something that now is the time for you
to do this you've been thinking about
this for 10 years you didn't ask for
permission from me on this issue i'm
going to give you permission without you
asking you need to get qualified now now
is the time for you to get studied up
and and i want you to find some
different real estate people who have a
much different outlook you've been
hanging around some people who are
giving you the negatives um i don't need
to know the context of those
conversations but the fact is you can
win and you can win big even in this
real estate economy if you are committed
to do it committed to get good at it
committed to work with a a broker who's
going to mentor you and guide you and
invest in you you can do this yeah and
you need to do it starting next week go
ahead and get your license signed up for
to take your test and jump in and find a
broker and and get all your groundwork
and everything done this fall uh to
where january one you hit the ground
running wide open
cooking cook cooking with gash in
january one yeah you know in a new
jersey and in a used jeep cherokee
yeah
and listen if you make zero money for
six months and it starts to scare you go
get a job
okay after january okay right but yeah
but i think you you take the time align
yourself with a great broker get the
groundwork because it's going to take a
little while to study for sit for take
the test get the results back get signed
up the board of realtors all the stuff
you do you gotta you know you it takes a
hot minute to get to get set up you
don't just walk in and in a week you're
selling real estate in most cases anyway
and so um
yeah that that's exactly what i do i
would start i'll just go ahead it's time
burn the ships you know it's an old
phrase
just just you approach the island you
burn the ship i'm all in i'm not going
to no way home no way out of this deal
yeah you know dave that is true about
real estate or any sales job that's
that's straight commission you at some
point you got to commit to go i'm not
going to quit
i'm going to do whatever it takes and
you know in fort myers florida
you're going to be just fine yeah you're
going to be just fine that's correct
it's not exactly a slow market
yeah and it's not like you have to wait
till winter's over you're in fort
freaking myers i mean come on
so it's not do we where the snow thaws i
don't think so it's not going to be a
problem
all right there you go get after it
kiddo let us know how it turns out this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225 gary is with us in chicago hey
gary welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
thanks for taking my call it's really a
pleasure um my question is this my wife
and i about we're 50 years old uh about
10 years ago we figured out what we
wanted our retirement to look like and i
should mention we found you about one
year ago so
pre-dave ramsey we developed a plan
and we wanted our retirement to look
like a vacation property in keough
island a vacation property in park city
utah and somewhere else a third primary
home and so what we did was we went out
and bought a
rental property in both of those two
locations
uh took out a mortgage on both of those
two waterloo still had a mortgage on our
primary residence as well
for five years as we bought those
properties we got them and then about
five years ago we've been short-term
renting them they cash flow positive
they've been great we have better than
50 equity in all three of our properties
our primary residence and the two
rentals but we realize that's not the
dave ramsey way but we've got a good
income a good net worth the cash flow
and positive we're about 10 years away
from retirement and this is like our
dream so i kind of want to know what you
would do it sounds like based on your
personal experience we've got some risk
well i think everyone would agree that
debt equals risk
and more debt equals more risk
agreed
very much yeah
we have no other consumer debt so that
means you have less risk than other
people who have a lot of debt but you
have some risk so i can't tell what it
is so how much mortgage debt do you have
so to keep the numbers real simple we
owe five hundred thousand dollars on
each of the three properties our primary
residence we have a million and a half
in mortgage debt
correct but better than 50 equity
hurdles
yeah okay and your net worth is what
one point i'm sorry 3.3 net worth
so what's the other one and a half in
184
so it's it's uh 401ks and uh brokerage
accounts
okay
and how old are you guys
we're 50 and our household income is 400
000.
okay
i'm not panicking about this um
the only thing i would adjust
is
let uh you know here's the thing okay
it's not a dave ramsey thing
um it's just a when you when you scour
the people who have a net worth of 1 to
15 million
we find in the data and we did one of
the largest studies of millionaires ever
done a few years ago
we find in the data some commonalities
meaning that they're causal
okay
these things caused people to have this
net worth
one is they did what you did they built
a really nice retirement plan nice 401k
they usually got a million me and a half
like you've got in your 401ks your
brokerage accounts your retirement
accounts okay
two is they have paid for real estate
their home
so as an example a scaled-down version
of where you are what we found in the
millionaire study a lot was a a guy or
gal a couple with a 600 000 paid for
house and a million dollars in a 401k so
got a million dollar net worth or
million 1.5 1.6
net worth and they have zero debt
and um we find them at 52 years old
a lot like that like we found thousands
of those
that were millionaires it sounded just
exactly like that
so
what we've figured out is is that paid
for real estate going into retirement
having zero debt real estate or anything
going into retirement is a stabilizing
factor
and it makes your retirement
a lot less less stressful
so you said you're 50
you're 50. yeah and so if i woke up in
your shoes uh would i panic and go oh
dave ramsey says i gotta get out there
no this all real estate debt okay uh but
you make 400 freaking thousand dollars a
year
so how fast do we pay off with all these
rents coming in too how fast do we pay
off this million and a half
well i'm definitely to do it in a decade
yeah since i met you and online what
we've been doing we've created a little
debt-free chart and what we've decided
to do we've taken a rental property with
the highest interest rate on it and
we're going very intentional with that
one so all extra income whether it's
household or whether it's rental is
going to court against that one and then
we'll pay off the other rental and then
we plan on doing as we retire is
whatever equity is in our primary home
we're going to downsize into something
that size so we have no primary mortgage
on our primary home well or here's the
other thing
your million eight will be 3.2 in seven
years if it's in good mutual funds
yeah which it is yeah and so you reach
in there and touch it when you hit 60
and just pay it off and keep it if you
like the primary
you don't necessarily have to downsize
the primary how quickly can you pay off
a million dollars of the million and a
half
well i've got the one house planned at
four years it's a half million on that
one so i would think two we could do in
eight years probably quicker because
we'll get one paid off exactly yeah yeah
yeah i'd like to see do the whole thing
in about eight
i think we can i think with the
challenge yeah so if you get the 59 and
a half you got anything left just take a
little out of your retirement account
and pay it off
if you like all three properties still
and you still like your plan the only
thing i did was disturb you about the
debt
setting you up on a decade or less to be
clear of the debt if i'm in your shoes i
think that's fine
and let me tell you what will end up
happening
you're going to get obsessed with this
you're going to end up doing it quicker
i've already i've already got a side
hustle with my income trust me i'm going
he's he's doing driving uber making 400k
what is your side hustle do you mind was
asking
uh yeah yeah it's logistics so there's
companies around chicago that will help
you deliver you deliver things it's like
doing door dash but just not door
dashing because it's kind of funny
that's hilarious four hundred thousand
and he's got himself inside my wife my
wife thinks
yeah you kind of are what do you do what
do you do for a living
uh we're both in sales management so i i
talk about the virtues of sales careers
we we've been live in sales our whole
life and change our first thing thing
yeah well that's the other thing here's
what happens okay as you now you have a
new goal
that's got you fired up your sales are
going to go up
yeah but the level we are in sales now
we're out of the commission world we're
in the salary and bonus because we're in
management now so it's salary and bonus
so going up helps a little bit but not
as much as you would if you're
commissioned you know what i'm saying
yeah you know you could do a side hustle
with sales training for non-competing
companies you make a whole lot more in
doordash exactly just what do i know but
you know anyway you're doing great man
i'm so proud of you it's so cool i
appreciate you getting fired up on our
stuff and all it's going to do is just
increase your peace level as those
deaths start dropping off and even
putting them in the crosshairs and
knowing when they're going to drop off
the piece comes just from doing that
even though you haven't gotten there yet
just knowing you're gonna be able to
pull the trigger and knock them out
that's the thing so yeah that that's
beautiful yeah you'll probably end up
doing the whole thing in about six years
that's gonna be my production my
prediction
and uh just just this guy he his mind is
already moving so that's what i mean we
see people do it all time very seldom do
you hit your goals on this stuff you
almost always hit them early that's
right well and when you're focused right
whether it's losing weight or
relationship growth when you're focused
towards a goal then what happens is
things begin to move in your favor that
you didn't see and we hear that all the
time and it's just a function of
intentionality and and and hyper focus
activity and just things fall your way
and you know i actually would say you
know what you're getting bonus probably
on team performance instead of the door
dash i'd be working with these
individual team members that you and
your wife manage and lead help them grow
help them hit new goals boy is that
going to be fun and probably going to
fatten those bonuses i would guess if i
was leading a sales team yeah you know
yeah i think there's a lot of stuff you
can do it's fun it's fun i mean um but
your overall plan is not out of control
but keeping those debts forever would
not be my recommendation so let's just
develop a plan for getting rid of them
in some reasonable period of time
and uh and or when you hit 59 and a half
cash them out cash out because you're
going to be sitting on in excess of 3
million
probably in excess of four million
dollars in those retirement accounts at
that point
not counting your real estate and the
real estate will have continued to go up
too so you're gonna you know you're
gonna retire at
65 with a
7 million down worth give or take wow
that's a trek you're on uh if you can
especially if you continue to make a
freaking 400 grand you know that's that
does help the equation a little bit
but um up through some number of those
years so it's going to put you in a
great great place um well dave i can't
be a baby steps millionaire i don't make
400 grand
33
of the people that we found that became
millionaires in north america starting
from nothing with no inheritance
did so with an income less than 100
000. the third most likely category of
career to become a millionaire in the
study
was teachers
number one was engineer number two was
accountant number three was teacher
so there you go those are facts
they're not wishes
and they're not a political statement so
if you don't agree with them you're
what's known as wrong
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of church
choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships ken coleman ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author host of the ken coleman show is
my guest my guess my co-host this hour i
can't get anything out i'm just going to
stumble off this that's all right
we're here we're here we're going to do
this hour and it's all about baby steps
millionaires this hour if you are a
millionaire we want to talk to you we
want to know how you did it what you
what your situation looks like what
you've learned along the way
not what you're you know we want to talk
to real millionaires now for those of
you who don't know
there is a specific
and only one
definition of a millionaire
a millionaire is not someone that makes
a million dollars a year
it's not someone that's rich necessarily
unless you want to define that as rich
it is a mathematical equation
that decides if you're a millionaire
it's an accounting
function
from a balance sheet
it is your assets minus your liabilities
when that number
at the bottom of that equation assets
mass liabilities is one million dollars
or greater you are a millionaire well i
don't feel rich it's not a feeling well
no one should have a million dollars we
should all be socialists it's not a
moral construct
it's not about wealth equality it's not
about your broke brother-in-law's
opinion it's a freaking accounting thing
what you own minus what you owe
equals one million dollars then you are
a millionaire
not before not after
that's how it works
and so when i hear idiots like i heard
an idiot congressman the other day goes
well anybody that makes a million
dollars a year is a millionaire and they
shouldn't be i'm like you're an idiot
how did you get in congress
you're just stupid
well that's part of the job
qualification is to be an
what's broken on you but the uh um
anyway but yeah we so yeah there we go
i've got friends in congress i shouldn't
say that but i know it was too broad of
a brush
it was very close though it's just about
got them off it kind of so anyway the uh
um
so the deal is this we're going to talk
with real millionaires not your broke
brother-in-law with a political opinion
not your kid who's been influenced by um
a youtuber or a tick tocker worse can
you say soccer worse than that a tenured
college professor oh well he was a
communist okay but um never made payroll
so none of this matters this is a
discussion with real
millionaires how they got there if you
don't want to be one
ever because you think it's evil you
should turn this off because we're going
to tell you how to do it and it's going
to screw you up okay because we're going
to talk about real millionaires karen is
our first one she's in sheboygan
wisconsin a sheboygan millionaire always
wanted to say that that's very cool
karen what's your net worth
um about
1.7 maybe a little bit more good give me
the mix on that how much in real estate
how much in 401k and so on
sure a retirement at about 1.1
um we have a paid for home of 500 000
um about 180 000 in cash and then my
husband has his gt40 which is about
worth about 140 000.
i like him
all right 140 000 gt
good
how old are you guys
i'm 61 and he's 67. cool how much of
this 1.7 million did you inherit
uh when my father-in-law passed away
about 35 000 which we took and paid the
back side of our uh second home
how long ago was that
oh
geez 30 years ago maybe so did that make
you a millionaire
gosh no okay all right just making sure
okay because everybody says that all
millionaires inherited their money and
we know that statistically to be a
complete parse but so give me your best
year working in household income and
your worst year working household income
okay uh the best year was when he
retired uh at 190 000
and our worst year combined uh was about
50 000 when we first started out cool
what careers were you in
uh well i was pretty much a stay-at-home
mom after the kids went back to school
in middle school i became more of an
office decision administrative assistant
i retired from the park and rec
department now i work really part time
for that office and they're off that
administration how realistic is the
parks and rec show
you know i only watched it i only
watched it a couple of times
yeah it's one of the most fun best jobs
i've ever had though what'd your husband
do
my husband uh worked for the same
company for 42 years and but within that
company he had eight different positions
he retired as director of international
business development so he traveled all
over the world um so that's why i was
pretty much a stay-at-home mom for quite
a bit because uh i held down was his
what was his degree in
well he uh had a two-year associate
degree
uh and he had a 2.5 gpa there and then
worked for a while full time trying to
figure out what he was going to do
then went back to school and got his
bachelor's and master's at the same time
i was having children and his was in um
the business management side and he
ended up with a 3.5 in college when he
was older yeah very good very cool very
cool okay so now when you look back on
your all's lives
and you look at the current situation in
the united states today and you're
talking right now to a whole bunch of 25
year olds on this show
do you think that they can still start
with nothing and when they are 61 have
1.7 million net worth
oh gosh absolutely what should they do
to do that what are the keys
um
my husband wants me to tell you that he
recommends that you do do the community
college whether you start right out of
high school or not
but to continue working until you find
your career path
and that make sure that you take
advantage of the company college
reimbursements that helps so much
and the also the 401k matches my end i
would make sure
our biggest fault was the car loans to
stay away from those car loans credit
card gimmicks
and not have to compete you know don't
pay attention to what your friends your
neighbors have or things like that
you really don't need all that stuff you
can have a lot of fun
without it and then just to be
patient and that your hard work will be
rewarded in a lot of wonderful ways but
it just takes time so that's what we're
telling our 20 or 20 year olds too i
hear you you're hey you're wonderful
well done very well done congratulations
i'm proud of you
so ken the misnomer is that um
the wealthy all inherited their money
yeah and the only way you become wealthy
is to be crooked you have to be evil
because the wealthy are evil
um or they're all famous
they're basketball football player
they're a country music star a rock star
a hollywood actor
um
or they're brilliant they have an
inordinate brain matter right you know
they're all 4.4 gpas right um and all
four of those things it turns out
statistically are
lies yeah this is a a couple here where
he had a 2.5 community college only
went into work busted it later said all
right i want to get a masters to maybe
move up the ladder did that and
eventually became a 3.5 student much
later on so not not a 4.4 he's not a
rocket not a rocket surgeon just a hard
worker a guy who had a plan and went
after it i'm not a rocket surgeon and
he's not tom cruise
and they didn't steal anything
they didn't beat anybody up
they weren't in the mafia
they uh and they didn't inherit for 35
000
and by the way that's about the normal
thing
out of the 10 000 millioners that we've
studied we find lots of people just like
those fine folks so quit saying bad
things about millionaires they're my
friends
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is
my co-host today
dave every day we get calls for people
who've had enough enough credit card
payments enough relationship problems
enough overdrafting with their bank
account to pay for food and gas and
everyone here at ramsey we've been there
and we know how challenging it can be to
take that first step to say enough is
enough
and you could say enough i've this job i
have sucks i want ken coleman's stuff
that's right no you could say enough
when you say enough is when you change
your life when you yell it at the sky
enough
that's that's how it changes everything
the good news is you can decide today to
get out of the pattern that's getting
you nowhere
and that's why we've brought back the
ramsey ten dollar sale on our number one
best-selling books and tools the sale
ends
in august for most of you listening
that's right now today today is the last
day
learn the baby steps to climb out of
debt build wealth with books like our
best seller the total money makeover
questions for humans uh cards by dr john
daloni our my new little quick read
called the momentum theorem uh man
there's all kinds of stuff in here for
just 10
dollars all right and dave just said it
ends today but here's what else ends
today the ramsey cash giveaway there's
two amazing chances to jump start your
journey the resources to help you walk
the clear path to the success that you
want and then the cash to help fast
forward it you can enter the ramsey cash
giveaway for your chance to win the
grand prize of three thousand dollars so
today's the last day
you take a shot at three thousand
dollars
get the ten dollar deals all at
ramseysolutions.com don't miss the three
grand ramsey solutions
dot com this is an everyday millionaires
baby steps millionaires real
millionaires female or we're talking to
real millionaires the next one is
stephen salem oregon hey steve what's
your net worth
uh about 6.9 right now yeah i love it
okay wonderful give me a little
breakdown on that by category how much
of each type
well it's
almost entirely real estate uh very
little in
stocks and mutual funds uh i have a
little cash on hand but the vast
majority of it is in
real estate okay big real estate guy all
right any debt on it
a little bit uh i'm at about a 80
percent uh equity standing gotcha so
okay so a couple million in debt all
right cool yeah about maybe one and a
half somewhere around there how old are
you
52. okay cool and how much of the 6.9
did you inherit
zero
zero precisely all right and your uh
range of income your best year working
and your worst year working household
income
i would say
household income range between
80 to 120 000 a year okay cool and what
do you do for a living real estate
investor
uh so for most of my career i actually
started out as a teacher and was
actually investing in real estate while
i was doing that and
i was doing so many remodels i switched
my profession to remodeler so
so i was remodeling homes for about 27
years for others um and remodeling
anything that i would buy along the way
okay fun cool do you have a four-year
degree
yes
education
yeah in education okay what was your uh
gpa
uh in college uh
about 3.9 actually yeah good for you
very cool
okay so tell folks uh what's the secret
to having a seven million dollar net
worth at 52 years old is
i don't know if there's really a secret
you know i started young
and i think
you need to start thinking about the
future when you're young and i did i
bought my first house at age 24 and then
the next my first rental property at age
26. uh so i started early i knew that
there was
really i didn't have a big retirement
you know i didn't have a big 401k you
know ahead of me i didn't have anything
you know any big golden parachute to
lean on so i knew i had to get busy and
and get to it when i was early
uh because by the time i got older i was
going to be tired what's going to work
won't work so hard yeah cool
i always made sure that you know i was
willing to work harder than the guy next
to me and give service like nobody else
and
along the way i would just try to be
disciplined with my spending and
discipline with my investing
so i often ask people how much
debt uh was a
factor that how much did they use debt
to build wealth and in your case you did
a little bit at least a little bit right
in the beginning i used a lot and i used
too much and uh that came back to bite
me uh back in the crash of o8 and
i was afraid i was going to lose
everything dave
i actually probably lost about half of
my portfolio and uh
and so if you had it to do over you
would not do it that way i would not i
would not leverage in the way i did
absolutely not uh i was leveraging like
crazy
and i know you you have a story that's
somewhat similar and uh
you know i i didn't have anybody in in
front of me that i knew to uh so i could
learn from their mistakes i wish i did
but i got to learn from my own and those
are the most painful but also the most
memorable
they're thorough it's thorough
yes
and it took me about 12 or 13 years to
crawl back out of that hole dave but you
know i never uh i was at the point where
i thought i might have to uh
claim bankruptcy but i didn't i just
you know i i didn't feel right about
that and i thought you know if the good
lord gives me the ability to work
and if i can deal with these creditors
to uh to to do what's right what and pay
back what i promised that i would do
that and i thought that was the
honorable thing to do so it took me a
long time to crawl out of that hole
very well done the moral of the story of
course is uh
that uh that you a survive but b if you
were doing it over you would use at
least less debt yeah um and and not be
as leveraged that's the moral of the
story yeah so and more in our direction
but way to go man congratulations i love
it you know dave there's a great
instruction here it's teacher by trade
and you know a lot of young people are
buying a lot of the messaging out there
all over social media that hey i can
leverage my way into a lot of money and
i hope they hear there's tremendous
tremendous risk that he almost lost at
all yeah well that's exactly right
allen's with us in atlanta alan what's
your net worth
it is my net worth is about 3.8 million
cool give me a little break down on that
by category
all right the way it breaks down is i've
got about eight hundred thousand dollars
in real estate all paid off
i have about 200 000 in cash
500 000 in a 401k and 2.3 million in my
equity account
good for you
very good all right cool how old are you
i'm 46 years old and i'm married to a 45
year old
wife perfect and how much did you
inherit of this 3.8 million
inheritance is never going to be uh
part of what happens to us dave so zero
okay
and your range of income during your
working life your best year since you've
been married your best your worst year
uh i mean it fluctuates a lot because my
wife's earned her doctorate degree since
we've got married and teaching and so
that kind of helped a lot but i would
say the lowest that we've made is
probably around 200 000
and uh the highest we've made probably
right around five hundred thousand
okay so
say you made 500 high-end
yes sir yep while doing what
uh my wife's a teacher she teaches high
school math and i'm an engineer oh okay
i do technical sales
okay cool
all right so there's two of our top
three uh
categories of uh
careers that become millionaires in your
3.8 million at 46. okay so what's the uh
obviously you got an education degree uh
you said you got a phd and you got an
engineering degree correct
uh well i have a i only have an
associate's degree i don't have a
four-year degree i'm in school now to
complete one but uh yeah i've got a
two-year associate's degree that i know
if you don't hurry up and do that you're
probably going to be a failure
we're really concerned right now
i mean you make a half a million dollars
a year and you're 46 and you got 3.8
million
yeah you've been really held back by
this hey way to go all right in 30 in in
10 seconds what is the most important
thing someone should do if they want to
be you
stay out of debt live in self-imposed
scarcity and invest like your life
depends on it not only financially but
in your understanding
i love that
pose scarcity beautiful and he did it
all in 10 seconds too that was that is
impressive didn't mess up the commercial
way to go alan this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today best-selling author of the
book paycheck to purpose
we're talking to millionaires baby step
millionaires people that followed the
baby steps and did it or just
millionaires maybe they did it some
other way open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
as we talked to actual
millionaires a few years ago our
research team here in conjunction with
an outside research team to confirm that
our methodologies were airtight
and that there wasn't any uh
bias in our process
did what became the largest study ever
done
of millionaires in north america
my friend tom stanley that did the book
the millionaire next door passed away in
a car wreck a few years ago his daughter
sarah is still continuing his research
uh in atlanta and you've got to check
that out it's incredible research
but tom's book millionaire next door had
a
statistically significant sample
of millionaires but was always
criticized because most of the
journalists that write critical articles
about things like this that are
socialists never took a math class or a
statistics class and so they don't know
what statistically significant means but
the study sample size for the
millionaire next door that became a
famous book was 750 millionaires and he
was always criticized for that being so
small so we said you know we understand
that his data was accurate at the time
it was written in 1992. we want to do a
fresh study
but we're also going to go ahead and
just beat up on the stupid publicity
side of this thing and we'll do 10x of
statistically significant we want to
study 7 500. well before we got wound
down we ended up with 10 167 that we had
done so it's over 10 000 actual
millionaires that we talked to and
here's some of the interesting things we
found
68 percent use a financial advisor
73 percent of millionaires never held a
penny of credit card debt in their
entire lives
7 out of 10 never had a student loan
compared to one percent
seventy percent didn't 51 percent of the
public has
uh top three jobs we said this earlier
engineer accountant and teacher in kenya
like this and you knew this of course
ninety six percent enjoy what they did
for a career sixty 64 so they loved
their jobs yeah yeah i mean turns out
that when you're doing something you
were created to do you do it really well
and get rewarded for it you make more
money yeah hello
one-third of millionaires 33 never had a
six figure one hundred thousand dollar
household income in a single working
year
that's extraordinary less than 100k yeah
the average millionaire lives in a 2600
square foot home that they've been in
for 17 years the average millionaire
pays off their home in 10 or in 11 years
in our tribe the ones that have gone
through baby steps are more like 10.2
years a little faster 94 say they live
on less than they make compared to 55
percent of the general population 93 use
coupons
uh most of them hit became millionaires
at an average age of around 49 years old
so you hear somebody 50 years old that
just became a millionaire that's a
that's a normal thing
uh some do it faster some do it slower
but that's the average 97
of millionaires said they believe they
control their own destiny
what dr deloney would call locus of
control
versus when you uh when you
survey the public the public's 63
percent
not 97 say they believe they control
their own destiny and by the way if you
don't think you control your own destiny
you won't work on it so there's a
there's a correlation of causation there
uh 70 say they set some of their income
aside every month to give to others
seven out of ten are generous
every month yeah every single month with
a rhythm of their life is generosity and
here's the key one they did not inherit
their money that is the biggest lie
and piece of mythology that is floating
around
okay out of the largest study of
millionaires
ever done what we found was 79 of them
inherited precisely zero
five percent
inherited
a small amount like five thousand
dollars from grandma when she died or
one guy said earlier here 1300 bucks or
something right
that kind of thing
and another five percent inherited
substantial monies but after
they were already millionaires so they
might have got a hundred thousand bucks
or something but they were already
millionaires so
five and five and seventy nine
for those of you struggling that's 89
9 out of 10 of america's millionaires
mathematically did not become
millionaires because of an inheritance
now when we publish that
these stupid butt people that comment on
stuff like instagram
and by the way some of you that comment
you really should keep your
stupid mouth shut because it makes you
look stupid because you are it's just
ridiculous and just you know it's just
crazy you know well they grew up in
privilege
no they didn't
no they didn't
they didn't why mom and daddy paid for
everything no they didn't
they just didn't
these millionaires when we talk to them
they they laugh at you ignoramuses that
say stuff like that
all you're doing is whining because you
don't have enough husba to get up off
your little butt and go out there and do
something and you'd rather sit around
and whine like a socialist snowflake
instead of actually going and getting
something done
and and so the pro the problem is when
you do stuff like that people believe
your stupid butt and you're what's known
as called a hope stealer you steal hope
from people that's why i ended up
writing the new book that became a
number one bestseller baby steps
millionaires which again has the entire
study in the back because i got tired of
listening to you hope stealers and i had
to go through and show people the actual
facts that yes it's hard
way
but yes it can be done every race every
creed every religion every region
every sex they're all represented
in the in the study that we did and
write down the dead gum lines of
statistical i mean
significance it's right where it should
be that's right it's just you know
is it harder for some people do they
start further in the hole yeah
but do they still do it
every
day you whiners
every day don't be a whiner it's not
becoming it's not good so we're talking
to real millionaires not whiners not
people who vote the wrong way not people
are there confused about this stuff
and real millionaires that really did it
michaela is one of them she's in boston
michaela what is your net worth
well i think just under 3 million like
around two point seven two point eight
okay i'm gonna go with 2.8 based on you
all right and give me a little breakdown
on that what's the
categories
so i have a roth ira that i started
right out of college
my first job
and
how much is in it so
about i'd say it goes up and down but
about 800. okay cool all right
and then i have
two houses or two properties to live in
and one piece of land what's all that
worth
and so i'm gonna say
um to
about two point six two okay
that's that's the whole thing then okay
cool how old are you
61. okay cool you're single
yes all right and what did you do for a
living
so um i've believe it or not been
a modern dancer
and a real estate broker a dancer
and i kind of split the two up
so i didn't make as much as a lot of
brokers do but i have a really good
balance selection
okay i love it that's fun how much of
this 2.8 did you inherit
zero okay zero and what was your best
year working income and your worst year
working income
well so my worst probably was about 11
000 when i first started
and my best was when i decided to buy
the three properties
so i had i worked really hard in real
estate for that one year and so that was
almost 300 000
so that i could qualify to buy got it
okay very cool you have a four-year
degree
i do in what
in political science
political science perfect okay what was
your gpa
uh three
four three five i think okay very cool
so what advice would you have to the
younger version of you that's in their
20s that's listening to this if they
want to have 2.8 million net worth when
they're 61 years old
well um i never ever dreamed i would own
property i just didn't think that would
happen for me so
um just
to believe that you can do it and set
out to do it
that belief thing that 97 of the
millionaires we surveyed said they
believed they could do it there it is
right there well done michael i'm proud
of you you're awesome absolutely amazing
beautiful beautiful stuff
and i love the mix modern dance and real
estate yeah this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day mark 10 45 for
even the son of man did not come to be
served
but to serve
and to give his life a ransom for many
don meyer said discover your gift
develop your gift and then give it away
every day
who's don meyer ken one of the greatest
basketball coaches of all time that most
people don't know about you'll know him
from he was at lipscomb university for a
long time when they were division three
and then he ended up his career won a
couple national champions several
national championships with lipscomb
and uh he mentored pat summitt
he's one of those small college guys
that like all basketball coaches know
but most people don't know because he
never was d1 discover your gift develop
your gift and then give it away every
day sounds like a ken coleman quote well
it certainly uh certainly is what we
teach uh that you were you were gifted
with what you have to give it away
created to contribute it's a millionaire
theme hour the book baby steps
millionaire is a number one bestseller
it's my latest if you want to learn more
about this subject
i'd be honored to teach you in that
method
stuart's with us in arizona stewart
what's your net worth
hey dave um my net worth is 2.3 million
good for you give me a little break down
by category
okay sure so um we have 430 000 in
mutual funds
we have my wife and i both have just
started roth a few years ago we have 50
000 there
we have 320 000
uh as liquid cash
and then we have 1 million 535
000 in real estate
cool all paid for
paid for awesome how old are you
39.
cool very good and how much of this did
you inherit
zero cool and what was your uh record
income and your your best year income
and your worst year income since you've
been working
um so i'll reverse that on you my my
lowest year was 9 000 this was i'm
self-employed um so i was just getting
my feet on the ground and um
you know you got to start with something
and so that was my lowest year
my cpa kind of looked at me and before
he gave me my tax total and said
how are you feeding the kids
and then you went on to you know let me
know that we'd made 9 000 that year yeah
um but then as our company grew i wanted
to keep as much cash flow in the company
as possible and so i just put myself on
a really modest
salary taxable income what was your best
year taxable income
uh 60 000
no you kept all the cash in the company
you're not counting that you paid taxes
on the cash you kept in the company
with cash in the company we did a 1.3
million dollar a year and a couple years
ago there we go okay i thought you were
killing it all right that makes more
sense
all right and your career what does your
company do
so i'm a builder i'm a general
contractor oh okay all right very good
good for you and you have a four-year
degree
no okay no degree all right cool cool
what advice do you have to a young
person listening to us that wants to
have a 2.3 million net worth when
they're 39 way to go
so i think that the the biggest thing
for me looking back is
do
hard things
um
a very motivational speech for me was
recently discovered from john f kennedy
in 1962
he said
we choose to go to the moon
not because it is easy but because it is
hard
and for me that's been a major blessing
in my life was coming to a fork in the
road and knowing that you can take the
easy pass
but intentionally choosing the difficult
path and it doesn't pay off overnight
but it does pay off yeah that is that is
a
a speech that should be required to be
memorized like the gettysburg address
yeah absolutely
he was a world-class orator and
motivator
yeah sorely missed
and his sentences had actually made
sense and stuff so there you go man way
to go dude i'm so proud of you
thank you i i gotta ask you real quick
uh you don't have a degree and we know
your first year of your company was nine
thousand how what was your path to
become a contractor who is very
successful building homes
well so like dave mentioned you know
with the statistics um i'm a big thomas
stanley fan read you know all of his
work and as i read these i i could see
myself in these other
people that he would interview and and i
think for me it just kind of came down
to at a young age so the reason i didn't
go to college is because i was home
schooled and you know i wanted to work
and so i actually started working a
40-hour a week job at the age of 15 and
a half
my parents said stuart you can go into
full-time work
when you get your graduation from high
school that really motivated me and from
day one i was
i was out there but it took me two or
three jobs to determine that i really
liked creating things with my two hands
yes and i especially liked creating
things that i could drive by years later
and say
hey i built that you know and i can take
my kids by their nowadays before they
were even born and say hey guess what
dad built that house
and um i just love getting my hands
dirty to this day um so did you start
working for a builder did you learn from
a builder or did you just start getting
into remodels yourself yeah so a core
value of mine as a young i started at 18
years old my wife and i got married 18
and i started my business that same year
and i started mowing lawns oh okay and a
customer would say hey stuart you're
mowing our lawn but you build fences and
i i had this core value in my head and
my value was never say
no
and so they would say you know we'd like
to pay to build a fence so i'd build
them a fence and then they go do you do
decks yes we do decks
you know so we'd build a deck and it
just grew and grew and grew to the point
where ten years down the road we were
doing multi-million dollar homes and
i got into some um some public works
which obviously you know is a great um
it's a great avenue
um
and i just i just always had a keen
sense of wanting to kind of sniff out
like what makes me happy
you've got you
with your hands self-made guy in the
truest sense of the word when someone is
out there floating around in our economy
today and they say things like um
you know the wealthy are evil and they
should pay more in taxes does that do to
you what it does to me
absolutely
yeah
yeah because i mean i i i understand
what it took to create this
um you know sleepless nights
many hours away from my wife and kids
and sometimes i hear people say you're
so lucky and i'm like lucky had nothing
to do with it you butt
yeah
yeah absolutely blessed i'll take
blessed yes i am so blessed
no question about it and and i have no
question i did not do this by myself uh
god's blessings and the blessings of
incredible people coming alongside and
helping me but luck
no this is not a random lightning strike
yeah absolutely
yeah that's just that that's we have got
to break that cycle off of these next
two generations that somehow this is
just random corn does not randomly grow
it is planted yep
you reap what you sow and you sir have
worked your butt off i can hear it in
their stories
thanks dave i mean you've had you you've
you've had some nights when you got home
and your hands were sore and your back
was sore and you got up the next day
before the sun came up and we went at it
again you've had a bunch of those
yes absolutely yeah i i'm i'm 39 now and
i'm just now getting to take my first
break
um we've had a great run for 20 years
and i decided last year to take some
time travel the country in an rv
you know we homeschool five kids my wife
does so i'm gonna be taking some time to
be a little bit more helpful with that
we're not done
but now we get to choose the things that
we get to do and the jobs we take yeah
and you should sir very very well done i
love that he gets to choose he just went
back to his went back to the kennedy
thing
he chose to work hard he chose to
sacrifice he's making over a million
dollars for his company and only pays
himself 60 but he's sitting there with
all this net worth plus 320 in cash
rving uh i mean he now gets to choose he
and his wife get to choose
what they want to do at the very young
age i might point out of 39 yeah
yeah not even 40.
that's that's incredible that's the
american dream by the way it's still
very much throw him out of the house at
15 and send him to the salt mines
salt mines i mean 15 years old he's
working a 40-hour week
yeah lee
oh i love this guy what a wonderful
story hey that puts a millionaire theme
hour in the books good job ken
good job james andrew zach ben and
austin in the booth the booth dudes i am
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you